The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: I
think, last time, we
got as far as talking
about processing of foams
and we talked a bit about
processing of polymer foams.
And today, I want to pick
up where we left off.
And I was going to talk
about processing metal foams.
We'll talk a little bit about
carbon foams, ceramic foams,
and glass foams.
We'll finish this section
on processing today
and then we'll start
talking about the structure
of cellular materials.
And hopefully-- we
won't finish that today,
but we'll finish it the
start of tomorrow's lecture.
And then, we'll start doing
mechanics of honeycombs
tomorrow.
OK?
So that's the scheme.
I thought what I'd do-- I have
a whole series of slides that
show, schematically, a
variety of different processes
for making metal foams.
So I thought I would just
go through the slides-
and I think I did this really
quickly last time-- but I would
write down a little bit of
notes on each of the slides
so that you've got
some notes on it, too.
This is the first method here.
And many of these methods were
developed for aluminum foams.
But you could, in principle, use
them for other types of foams,
as well.
This first method
here-- let me see
if I can get my little pointer.
[INAUDIBLE] The idea here is
that you take molten aluminum.
Down in this bath here,
you've got molten aluminum.
And they put, into the aluminum,
silicon carbide particles.
And the silicon
carbide particles
adjust the viscosity
of the melt.
They make it more viscous.
And then they just have a--
I've got this thing here--
they've got a tube here
that they blow gas in with.
And if you go to the
bottom of the tube,
there's an impeller, or a little
paddle, that stirs the gas up.
And so the gas just forms
in the molten aluminum here.
And then they have
conveyors which
pull off the molt-- or the
metal foam, and then it cools.
The idea is that if you
just had the aluminum,
you couldn't really do this
because the bubbles would
collapse before they cooled
down and became a solid.
But adding the silicon
carbide particles increases
the viscosity of
the melt. It helps
prevent drainage of the foam.
Normally, if you have a liquid
foam, just from gravity,
you're going to
have some drainage.
It's going to tend to-- some
of the liquid is going to tend
to sink, just from gravity.
By putting the silicon
carbide particles in,
you increase the viscosity.
It helps prevent the drainage.
And you can get the foam
bubbles to be stable.
Let me just write
one little note here.
The first method here
involves just bubbling gas
into the molten aluminum.
And that molten
aluminum is stabilized
by silicon carbide particles.
Sometimes people use aluminum
particles and the particles
increase the
viscosity of the melt.
And that reduces the drainage
and it stabilizes the foam.
That process was developed
at Alcan in Canada
and at Norsk Hydro in Norway.
And this foam here is an example
of the foam that they've made.
And you can kind of
see-- there's a density
gradient in this foam.
I'll pass it around.
You can see it.
But the bubbles are smaller down
here and there's fewer of them
than there are up here.
And that's partly
from the drainage.
The molten aluminum
is draining down
and you get more
liquid at the bottom
and then you get more
solid at the bottom.
So that's the Alcan foam.
OK.
Another-- there's half a
dozen of these processes
for metal foams.
Another version of the process
involves taking metal powder
and combining it with
titanium hydride powder.
And then you consolidate
it and you heat it.
So if I can show through
the schematics here.
In the first step, you take the
two powders, you mix them up.
So the second thing down here
is mixing the powders up.
And then you press
them together.
There's a dye here
that you press it,
and then you get pieces.
And then you can heat that up.
And the way that this
works is that the titanium
hydride decomposes at
a temperature of about
300 degrees C. And if the
other powder is something
like aluminum-- aluminum melts
at something like 660 degrees
C-- the aluminum has become
soft at 300 degrees C,
but it's not molten.
And the titanium hydride--
when it decomposes--
forms hydrogen gas.
So the hydrogen gas
forms the bubbles
that you need to make the foam.
Are you riding your bicycle?
You are tough.
Very tough.
I ride my bike, but I gave
up a couple weeks ago.
Well, three weeks ago, I guess.
When it started
snowing, I gave up.
The idea with this process is
you can use titanium hydride
powder with aluminum
and the aluminum becomes
soft at the temperature that
the titanium hydro decomposes.
And when it forms
the hydrogen gas,
that gives you the
bubbles, and so you get
the foam made by that process.
And that was developed by
a place called Fraunhofer.
And I have one of their
little foams here.
This is an example of their foam
made by that powder metallurgy
process there.
OK.
Let me just write a
little note about that.
So you can mix up titanium
hydride powder with a metal
powder and then heat that up.
When you do this, you need
to have a metal powder that's
going to be deforming by,
say, high temperature creep
at the temperature that the
decomposition of the titanium
hydride happens.
And for aluminum, that works.
So you need to have
the metal material be
able to deform fairly
easily, in order
to get these bubbles
to form a nice foam.
But that's another
way you can do it,
is by consolidating
these two powders.
Here's another way to do it.
You can also make use of
this property of the titanium
hydride-- that it'll
decompose and form
hydrogen gas-- by just putting
it into molten aluminum.
And in this example here, you've
got an aluminum melt in here.
And this time, they've
added 2% calcium to it.
Again, to adjust the viscosity.
And then they add the titanium
hydride in this step here
and they've got a
little mixer thing here
that's spinning around
and will mix it.
And then they'll put a lid
on it to control the pressure
and the titanium
hydride will decompose,
the hydrogen gas will
evolve, and you'll
get the foam made
by that method, too.
So you can stir titanium hide
right into a molten metal,
as well.
OK.
So that's another method.
And I think that was made by
something called the Alporas
process.
And this is an example
of one of their foams.
I'm pretty sure that's
an Alporas foam there.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: They can't
really control it perfectly.
In that first example
that's going around-- maybe
you might have missed it--
there's this drainage.
The first one's made by a molten
process and you get drainage.
And you get different
sized bubbles.
And you get different--
you get a density
gradient in the thing, as well.
So you can't control
these things perfectly.
OK.
Here's another method
for the metal foams.
This one here
involves replication.
In this method here, what
you do is you start out
with an open-cell polymer foam.
In this step up here, there's
an open-cell polymer foam.
You fill that with sand.
So you fill up all the open
parts of the cells with sand.
Then you burn off the polymer.
And so you've got
a little channels
where the polymer used to be.
And then you infiltrate those
channels with the molten metal
that you want to use.
So you replicate the
polymer foam structure.
This is the infiltration
process here.
This little thing
here is your furnace.
And then you get rid
of the sand and then
you're left with a metal
replica of the-- a replica
of the original polymer foam.
And this example here is one
of these things that's made
by this replication process.
So that's an
open-celled aluminum.
I think the-- if you look at
the density of these things,
they're fairly low.
And so there's quite a
large volume of pores
and they're all interconnected.
So it's not that hard
to get the sand out.
This method would
involve replication
of the open-cell foam-- the
polymer foam-- by casting.
So you fill the open-cell
polymer foam with sand.
You burn off the polymer.
And then you infiltrate
the metal into that.
And then you remove the sand.
OK?
Then, another process involves
just using vapor depositions.
So you take an open-cell
polymer foam again.
Here-- let me use
my little arrow.
Here's the open-cell
polymer foam up here.
And you have a furnace here
with a vapor deposition system.
And they use a nickel
CO4 system to do this.
You then burn out the polymer.
You're left with a metal
foam with hollow cell walls,
where the polymer used to be.
And then usually, what
they do is they center it.
They heat it up again to
try to densify the walls.
The only teeny weeny
problem with this process
is that the gas they use
this incredibly toxic.
And so it's not cheap and it's
got health hazards, as well,
associated with it.
But you can do it.
That gives you a nickel foam
when you're finished with that.
And you could also use an
electrodeposition technique
that's similar.
OK.
That's another method.
Another method is shown here.
This is the entrapped
gas expansion method.
And what they do in this
method is they have a can
and the can has a
metal powder in it.
It's whatever metal you want
to make the foam out of.
In this example here-- it's
probably too small for you
to read in the seats--
but it's titanium.
They've taken a titanium alloy.
They've got a powder
of titanium alloy.
They then evacuate the can.
They take all the air out of it.
And then they back
fill it with argon gas.
They put in an
inert gas in there.
And then what they do is
they pressurize and heat
the thing up and so
the gas is internally
pressurized by doing that.
And then, sometimes
when they do this,
they want to have a
skin on the two faces.
So in this next
little image here,
it's done where
they roll the can
and produce a panel
that's got solid faces.
And then when you heat
it up, the gas expands
and you end up with a
sandwich panel by doing this.
So this bottom
figure down here--
I'm not having much
luck with the pointer.
This bottom figure down
here, they've heated it up.
The gas expands and
you've got this solid skin
on the thing, which is from
where the can use to be.
So that's trapping of a gas.
OK?
There's a couple more
methods for the metal foams.
One involves centering hollow
metal spheres together.
And the trick there is to
make the hollow spheres.
And the way that can be done
is by taking titanium hydride
again, if you want to
make titanium spheres.
You put it in an organic
binder-- in a solvent--
so you've got a slurry here.
And you've got a tube
that you blow gas through.
And as you do that, you
get hollow titanium hydride
bubbles.
And then you can do the same
thing where you heat that up.
The hydrogen gas evolves off,
and you're left with titanium.
You're left with
titanium spheres
down at the bottom here.
And then you can
pack those together
and press those and form a
cellular material that way.
You can also center
hollow metal spheres.
And the last method I've
got for the metal foams
is that you can use
a fugitive phase.
With the fugitive phase,
you would take some material
that you could get rid of
at the end of the process.
Say, something like salt,
that you could leach out.
Here, we have our
bed filled with salt.
And then you would infiltrate
that with a liquid metal,
typically under pressure.
And then, after the metals
cooled, you leech out the salt.
You get rid of that.
You can pressure infiltrate
a leachable bed of particles,
and then leach
the particles out.
OK.
We have a whole
variety of methods
that have been developed
to make metal foams.
And most of these have
been developed, probably,
in the last 20 years.
Something like that.
Some of them are a little
bit older than that.
But there's been a lot of
interest in this recently.
Those are all methods
to make metal foams.
I wanted to talk just a little
bit about a few other types
of foams.
People make carbon foams.
And they use the
same kind of method
as they do to make those
bio carbon templates
I told you about.
When you take wood and you heat
it up in an inert atmosphere
and it turns into
a carbon template,
you can do the same thing
where you take a polymer foam,
you heat it up in
an inert atmosphere,
and everything except
the carbon is driven off.
And you're left
with a carbon foam.
It's the same process they
used to make carbon fibers.
There's carbon foams.
There's also ceramic
foams that you can make.
I brought the little sample
of ceramic foaming again.
You can pass that around.
And those are typically made
by taking an open-cell polymer
foam and passing a ceramic
slurry through the polymer foam
so that you coat the cell walls.
And then you fire it so that
you bond the ceramic together
and you burn the polymer off.
And you're left with a foam
that's got hollow cell walls.
You can also make ceramic
foams by doing a CVD process
on the carbon foam
that you could
make by the previous process.
And people also
make glass foams.
And to make glass
foams, they use
some of the same
kinds of processes
as people use for polymer foams.
I'll just say similar
processes to polymer foams.
OK.
That covers making
the foams, and I
think we talked about
the honeycombs last time.
I wanted to talk a
little bit about making
what are called 3D
lattice materials, or 3D
truss materials, as well.
Let me [? strip ?]
that up there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: Chemical
vapor deposition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
use this for metal foams?
LORNA GIBSON: Well, people were
quite interested in using them
for sandwich panels-- the
cores of sandwich panels--
lightweight panels.
There was interest in using
them for energy absorption,
say, car bumpers.
The automotive industry was
quite interested in this,
in terms of trying to make
components with sandwich
structures that would
be lighter weight,
or energy absorption
for bumpers.
Or filling up-- if you take--
say you take a metal tube.
If you think of a car chassis
and it's made of tubes,
if you fill those
tubes with a foam--
especially if you fill
them with a metal foam--
you can increase the energy
absorption quite substantially.
So when you have a
tube in a chassis,
if it's loaded axially,
it will fold up
and you get all these
wavelengths of buckling.
And if you've put
a foam in there,
it changes the
buckling wavelength
and it increases the amount
of energy you can absorb.
So not only is the energy
absorbed by the foam
itself, it actually changes
the buckling of the tube
so you can absorb more energy.
So there was a lot
of interest in that.
There was an interest
in using them
for cooling devices for,
say, electronic components.
The idea was you
would take, say,
an aluminium
open-cell foam and you
would flow air through that.
And say you have your device
that's generating heat,
you'd have a foam underneath it.
And the aluminum conducts
the heat fairly well.
And then you would
blow air through it
to try to cool it off.
So there were a bunch of
different applications
people have had
in mind for them.
AUDIENCE: What about glass?
LORNA GIBSON: Glass
foams, I think,
are largely used for
insulation in buildings,
believe it or not.
I think, actually, one of
the dorms at MIT-- maybe
the Simmons dorm-- has
a glass foam insulation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: Well, I
think because the foam--
because the cells are closed,
the gas is trapped in the cell.
Whereas with a fiberglass, gas
could move through the fibers
more easily.
So I think that's
partly how it works.
OK.
Well, let me talk a little bit
about the lattice materials,
too, and how we make those.
We're going to start
talking about the modeling
of honeycombs and foams.
And when we do that, we're
going to see that if we have
a structure that
deforms by bending,
the properties vary with
the amount of material,
in a certain way.
But if we have materials where
the deformation is controlled
by axial deformation, the
stiffness and the strength
are going to be higher
at the same density.
People made these
lattice-type materials
to try to get
something with a more
regular structure,
and especially
a triangulated structure.
You see how these things
are like little trusses?
Triangulated?
Triangulated
structures, when you
load them-- say I
load this like this--
there's just axial
components-- axial forces
in each of the members.
And so, theoretically,
this would
be higher stiffness and
strength for a given weight
than, say, a foam would be.
So people were interested
in these lattice material.
This one here is
made of aluminum.
And I wanted to talk
a little bit about how
you can make these things.
One way you can do it
is by injection molding.
And this here is just the
centerpiece of something
that would look like this.
So there would be a--
I didn't bring it,
but there's a top face and a
bottom face that fit onto this.
And they would be
injection molded
as three different pieces,
and then assembled together.
So you can make a mold in
this complicated geometry,
and you can make a lattice
material by injection molding.
We'll start with
polymer lattices first.
One way is injection molding.
Another way to do it
is by 3-D printing.
You can generate a structure
like that by 3-D printing.
You can also make
trusses in 2D and you
can make them so that you
can snap fit those together.
So you can make
little 2D trusses.
Here's a little
truss here and here's
a little piece of a truss here.
And you can make a
little snap fit joints.
Do you see how these ones
have little divots in them?
And you can make it so that
these things will fit together.
I think these
guys-- can I do it?
No.
You'd have to take-- oops.
Wait a minute.
No, it's not that way.
There we go.
So you can snap them
together like that.
OK.
I can't get it to-- there we go.
So you can do that.
And you do that
over and over again.
And if you do it
over and over again,
you get something
that looks like that.
OK?
You can make a snap fit thing.
Let me pass all
these guys around
and you can play with those.
That's the injection
molding one.
This is the snap-fit one.
Got that?
Let's see.
I think I have a
little picture here.
This is an example of
the snap fit truss here.
It's the thing that's
getting passed around.
And another clever
way that was developed
was by taking a monomer
that's sensitive to light.
You take a photo
sensitive monomer.
And you put a mask on top of it
and the mask has holes in it.
And then you shine
collimated light on it.
You shine, say, a laser on it.
And the light goes through
the holes in the mask.
And it starts to
polymerize the polymer
because it's photosensitive.
And then, as the polymer-- as it
polymerizes and becomes solid,
it then acts as a waveguide
and draws the light down
deeper into the monomer.
And so the polymer
acts as a wave guide.
It brings the light down.
And this is a
schematic over here.
This is a schematic
showing the set up.
And these are some
examples of some 3D trusses
that they've made
using this technique.
And one of the nice
things about this
is you can get a very
small size cell size.
So this is-- I think that
bar-- it says 1,500 microns.
That's what?
One and a half millimeters.
So you can get a nice, small
cell size if you want that.
Let me write that down.
You take a
photosensitive monomer
and then you have it in
a mold beneath a mask.
And then you shine
collimated light on it.
And as the light shines on it,
it polymerizes the monomer.
So then it solidifies and then
it guides the light deeper
into the monomer.
OK.
That's that.
And then finally, there's
metal lattices, as well.
And so this is, obviously,
a metal lattice here.
It's an aluminum alloy.
And the metal lattice
is made by taking
that polymer lattice that was
made by the injection molding
technique.
You coat that with
a ceramic slurry.
You burn off the
polymer, and then
you infiltrate the metal
where the polymer used to be.
OK.
That's the section on
processing of the honeycombs
and the foams and the lattices.
So there's a variety
of different techniques
that people have
developed for making
these kinds of materials.
And I thought it'd be
useful to just describe
some of the techniques.
As I think I said last time,
this isn't comprehensive.
This doesn't cover
every technique.
But it gives you
a flavor of what
techniques people have
developed for making
these kinds of materials.
OK?
Are we good?
We're good.
OK.
The next part, I want
to do on the structure
of cellular materials.
And I have a little overview.
I don't think we'll
finish this today,
but we'll finish it tomorrow.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: Down here?
AUDIENCE: What happens
to the ceramic?
LORNA GIBSON: They get
rid of the ceramic.
Typically, the ceramic
is not very strong
and it's just fired enough
so they can infiltrate it
with the metal.
And then they-- yeah, I think
with mechanical smushing
around, you can get
rid of the ceramic.
And the ceramic's brittle,
so if you break the ceramic,
you're not going
to break the metal.
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering if you could
make a type of metal
lattice [INAUDIBLE]
with reducing [? the ?] oxides?
LORNA GIBSON: I guess you
could, if you could-- but you'd
have to then make the
oxide in that shape, too.
You've always got to make
something in that shape.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, maybe
you could make a foam.
But to make these lattices, you
need this really regular kind
of structure and be able
to control the structure.
OK.
Let me scoot out of this set of
slides and get the next set up.
OK.
We want to talk about the
structure of cellular solids.
And we classify cellular
materials into two main groups.
One's called honeycombs.
This thing down
here is a honeycomb.
And honeycombs have polygonal
cells that fill a plane
and then they're prismatic
in the third direction.
So you can think of them
as just being a prismatic--
and they can be hexagons,
they can be squares,
they can be triangles--
but you can think
of them as prismatic cells.
And the cells are
just in a 2D plane.
And then we also have foams.
All of these ones over
here are foamed materials.
And they're made up
of polyhedral cells.
The cells themselves are
three-dimensional polyhedra.
And this slide
here shows a number
of different types of foams.
These ones are polymers up here.
These are two metals.
These are two ceramics.
This is a glass foam down here.
And this is another
polymer foam down here.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: No.
I just know that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LORNA GIBSON: I took those
pictures so I know that.
No, you can't tell
by looking at them.
In fact, that's one of
the things about how we
model the cellular materials.
The fact that their
structure is so similar
is what gives them
similar properties.
And they behave in similar
ways because they've
got similar structures.
OK.
We've got 2D honeycombs,
where we have polygonal cells
that pack to fill a plane.
And then they're prismatic
in the third direction.
And then we have what we call
3D cellular materials, which
are foams, which have
polyhedral cells.
And then they pack
to fill space.
The properties of all
of these materials
depend, essentially,
on three things.
They're going to depend on the
solid that you make it from.
If you make the material from
a rubber or from an aluminum,
you're going to get
different properties.
So they depend on the
properties of the solid.
And some of the
properties that we're
going to use that are important
for this type of modeling
are a density of the solid--
which I'm going to call rho
s-- a Young's modulus of the
solid-- which I'm going to call
es-- and some sort of
strength of the solid--
which I'm going to
call sigma ys for now.
And you could think
of other things.
There could be a fractured
toughness of the solid.
There could be other
kinds of things.
One thing that the properties of
the cellular material depend on
is the properties of the solid.
Another is the relative density
of the cellular material.
And that's the density of
the cellular thing divided
by the density of the solid.
And that's equivalent to the
volume fraction of solids.
So it makes sense that
the more solid you've got,
the stiffer and stronger
the material's going to be.
So it's going to depend on
how much material you've got.
And it also depends--
the properties also
depend on the cell geometry.
The cell shape can control
things like whether or not
the honeycomb or the foam
is isotropic or anisotropic.
You can imagine,
if you have a foam,
and you've got
equiaxed cells, you
might expect to have the same
properties in all directions.
But if you had cells that
were elongated in some way,
you might expect you'd
have different properties
in the direction that
they're elongated relative
to the other plane.
So cell shape can
lead to anisotropy.
For the foams, you
can also have what
we call open-cell and
closed-cell foams.
If you look at this
slide here, and we
look at this top right
images-- these two up here--
the one on the left in the
top is an open-celled foam.
There's just material
in the edges.
There's no faces.
And so a gas can flow
between one cell and another.
And then if you look at
the one on the right,
this is a closed-celled foam.
There's faces.
If you think of the
polyhedra, you've
got solid faces covering
the faces of the polyhedra.
For an open-cell foam,
you've only got solid
in the edges of the polyhedra.
And the voids are continuous,
so they're connected together.
And for a closed-cell
foam, you've
got solid in the
edges and the faces.
And then the voids are
separated off from each other.
So we'll say, the cells are
closed off from one another.
Another feature of the cell
geometry is the cell size.
And the cell size can
be important for things
like the thermal
properties of foams.
It's important for
things like the surface
area per unit volume.
But typically, for the
mechanical properties,
it's not that important.
And we'll see why that is
when we do the modeling.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For the closed-cell
foams-- because we can't really
see it without cutting it,
is it that all of the faces
are closed?
Or is it like some fraction
of the faces are closed?
LORNA GIBSON: If you look at
this one on the top right here,
they're pretty much all closed.
But the reason we have
this little picture
down here is some of them
are closed and some of them
are open.
So you can get ones
that are in between.
But typically-- this
is kind of unusual.
Usually, they're either
all open or all closed.
If we look at the
mechanical properties
of cellular materials,
typically the cell geometry
doesn't have that
much of an effect.
The relative density
is much more important.
The relative density,
we define as the density
of the cellular solid.
And when I use a parameter
like rho or e or something,
if it's got a star, it's
for the cellular thing
and if it's got an s,
it's for the solid.
So rho star is going
to be the density
of the cellular material.
And rho s is going to be
the density of the solid
it's made from.
And so the relative density
is just rho star over rho s.
And I just wanted to
show you how this is
the volume fraction of solids.
So rho star is going
to be the mass of solid
over the total volume.
Imagine you've got a honeycomb
or a foam and you've got,
say, a unit cube of
it, the sum total
volume of the whole
thing-- the density
of the cellular
material is going
to the mass of the solid
over the whole volume.
The density of
the solid is going
to be the mass of the solid
over the volume of the solid.
This is really just equivalent
to the volume fraction
of solids, how much
solids you've got.
And that's also n equal
to 1 minus the porosity.
Typical values for
cellular materials--
I think last time I passed
around one of those collagen
scaffolds-- those tissue
enineering scaffolds.
It was in a little plastic bag.
That collagen scaffold has
a relative density of 0.005,
so its 0.5% solid and 99.5% air.
And if we look at
typical polymer foams,
the relative
density is typically
between about 2% and 20%.
And if we look at something
like softwoods-- wood
is a cellular material.
And we look at softwoods,
the relative density
is usually between
about 15% and about 40%.
Something like that.
OK?
As the relative
density increases,
you get more material
on the cell edges,
and if it's closed-cell
foam, on the cell faces.
And the pore volume decreases.
And you can think of some limit.
If you keep increasing the
relative density more and more
and more, eventually you've
got-- it's not really
a cellular material anymore.
It's more like a solid with
little isolated pores in it.
And so there's two bounds.
And the density has to be less
than a certain amount for you
to consider it a cellular
material in the models
that we're going to
derive to be valid.
And if the relevant density
is more than a certain amount,
people model it as a
solid with isolated holes.
If I have a unit
square of material,
if it's a cellular
material, you might
expect that you've got pores
that would look like this.
And you've got relatively
thin cell walls,
relative to the length
of the material.
And for a cellular material,
typically, the relative density
is less than about 0.3.
And when we come to the
modeling for the honeycombs
and the foams, we're going to
see that the cell walls deform,
in many cases, by bending.
And that you can
model the deformation
by modeling the bending.
And that the bending
dominates the behavior
if the density is
less than about that.
And at the other
extreme, you can
imagine if you had just
little teeny pores.
I have a little pore
here and one here
and one there and one there.
That's not really a
cellular material.
It's just got a teeny
weeny little bit of pores.
And that could be modeled as
isolated pores in a solid.
Each one is acting
independently.
And people have found
that that is appropriate
if the relative density
is greater than about 0.8.
And then, in between,
there's a transition
in behavior between
the cellular solid
and the isolated
pores in the solid.
OK?
Are we OK?
The next thing I wanted to
talk about was unit cells.
Especially for honeycombs,
people often use unit cells.
A hexagonal cell
is an obvious one
to use to model this
kind of behavior.
For honeycomb materials,
you can have unit cells
and you can have different ones.
On the left here, we've got
triangles, in the middle,
I've got squares.
On the right-hand side,
I've got hexagons.
And you can see, even if you
have a certain unit cell,
there's also different
ways to stack it.
So the number of edges
that meet at a vertex
is different for, say, this
example on the top left
and this example
on the bottom left.
Here, we've got six members
coming into each vertex,
and here, we've got four.
And again, this stacking
for the two square cells
is also different.
So you can have different
numbers of edges per vertex.
Another thing to note
that's kind of interesting--
if you look at the
honeycomb cells here,
this one on the top left--
this equilateral triangle
one with the stacking-- and
this one on the top right--
the regular hexagonal cells--
those two are isotropic
for linear elastic behavior,
whereas all the other ones are
not.
So we have 2D
honeycomb unit cells.
We can have triangles,
squares, and hexagons.
They can be stacked
in more than one way.
And that gives different
numbers of edges per vertex.
And in that figure, a
and e are isotropic,
for linear elasticity.
OK.
When we come to
modeling the honeycombs,
we're going to focus
on the hexagonal cells.
We'll talk a little bit about
the square and triangular
cells, as well.
And then, for
foams, when you look
at the structure of a
foam, it's obviously
not a unit cell that
repeats over and over again.
But people started off trying
to model the mechanical behavior
of foams by looking at periodic
repeating polyhedral cells.
And there's three cells
here that are prismatic.
We're not really going to
talk about those beyond this.
So they're not really physically
realistic or interesting.
But people would use these two
cells here in initial attempts
to model foams.
And this one here is called
the rhombic dodecahedra.
Rhombic because
each of the faces
has four sides and dodecahedra
because each polyhedra has 12
faces.
I forget if I've bored
you with my Latin already.
Hedron means face in-- oh,
this is Greek, I think.
Hedron means face.
Do is two, deca is 10.
So dodeca is two plus 10.
It's got 12 faces.
OK?
So that's the rhombic
dodecahedra over here.
And then this bottom one down
here is a tetrakaidecahedra.
It's a similar thing.
Tetra's four, kai mean and.
Four and 10-- tetra kai
deca-- it's got 14 faces.
OK?
And those two pack
to fill space.
I think those are the
only uniform polyhedra
that pack to fill space.
Here is the 3D foams.
We have the rhombic dodecahedron
and the tetrakaidecahedron.
And the tetrakaidecahedron
packs in a bcc packing.
Initial models for foams--
they took these two unit cells.
And what they would do is
have an infinite array of them
to make up the whole material.
And then they would
isolate a unit cell.
And they would apply loads--
some say compressive stress,
for example.
And then they would figure out
what the load, or force, was
in every single member, and
how much that member deformed.
And they would figure
out the component
of the deformation
in the same direction
that they were
putting the load on.
And they would figure out
things like a Young's modulus,
or they would figure out when
there was some failure of one
of these struts, and
they would figure out
a strength for the foam.
But you can kind of
imagine, geometrically,
not that easy to keep straight.
A little bit complicated.
So one way to model foams is
by using these unit cells.
But we're going to talk
about a different way
to do it, as well.
OK.
So those are unit cells.
When they make foams,
as we just talked about,
one way to make a foam is by
blowing a gas into a liquid.
And if you blow a
gas into a liquid,
then the surface
tension is going
to have an effect
on the cell geometry
and on the shape of the cells.
And if the surface
tension is isotropic--
if it's the same in all
directions-- then the structure
that you get is one that
minimizes the surface
area per unit volume.
And so people were interested
in what sort of cell shape
minimizes the surface
area per unit volume.
And Lord Kelvin,
in the 1800s, was
the person who worked this out.
And this is called the
Kelvin tetrakaidecahedron.
And it's not just a
straight tetrakaidecahedron.
There's a slight curvature to
the cells here, to the faces.
And you can kind of see it
in some of the edges here.
Like if we-- let me
get my little pointer.
If you look at that
edge, it's not straight.
This edge here is not straight.
It's got a little bit
of a curvature to it.
But this minimizes the
surface area per unit volume.
And then more recently,
in the 1990's, there
were two people-- Dennis Weaire
and Robert Phelan-- discovered
that this structure here--
which isn't a single polyhedron,
but it's made up
of a few polyhedra.
That has a slightly smaller
surface area per unit volume.
Smaller by 0.3%.
So, a tiny bit smaller.
OK.
Let's see.
What I'll say here is
that foams are often made
by blowing a gas into a liquid.
And if the surface tension
controls and it's isotropic,
then the structure will
minimize the surface area
per unit volume.
OK.
That's relevant if
the foam is made
by blowing a gas into a
liquid and surface tension
is the controlling factor.
Sometimes foams are made
by supersaturating a liquid
with a gas, and then
you nucleate bubbles,
and then the bubbles grow.
So there's a nucleation
and growth process.
So that's a little
bit different.
And if you have a nucleation
and growth process,
you get a structure that
is similar to something
called a Voronoi structure.
In an idealized case,
imagine that you
have random points that
are nucleation points
and that you start
to grow bubbles
at those nucleation points.
So you start off with
these random points.
And the bubbles all start
to grow at the same time
and they all grow at
the same linear rate.
If you have that
situation, then you
end up with this Voronoi
kind of structure.
And I've shown a
2D version of it
here just because it's
easier to see in 2D,
but you can imagine a 3D system.
And in order to make one of
these Voronoi honeycombs,
you can imagine-- if you
have random points-- here,
say that little point there is
one of the nucleation points,
and here's another
point here-- you
form the structure by drawing
the perpendicular bisectors
between each pair of points.
This is the bisector
between these two points.
Here's a bisector
between those two points.
And then you form the
envelope of those lines
around each nucleation point.
And that, then, gives
you that structure.
And you can see, this structure
here is kind of angular.
It doesn't look that
representative of something
like a foam.
But if you have an
exclusion distance,
where you say that you're not
going to allow the nucleation
points to be closer than some
given distance-- your exclusion
distance-- then you get
this structure here.
And this starts
to look a lot more
like a foamy kind of structure.
So these Voronoi structures
are representative
of structures that are
related to nucleation
and growth of the bubbles,
or nucleation and growth
processes.
Let me write down something
about Voronoi things.
And these Voronoi
structures were first
developed to look at
grain growth in metals.
They weren't developed
for cellular materials.
But you can use them to
model cellular materials,
as well, as long as it's a
nucleation and growth process.
We'll say that
foams are sometimes
made by supersaturating
a liquid with a gas,
and then reducing the pressure
so that the bubbles nucleate
and grow.
So initially, the bubbles
are going to form spheres.
But as the spheres
grow, they start
to intersect with each other
and form polyhedral cells.
And you get the
Voronoi structure
by thinking about an idealized
case in which you randomly
nucleate the-- you have
nucleation points at a randomly
distributed space.
They start to grow
at the same time
and they grow at the
same linear rate.
OK.
The Voronoi honeycomb,
or the foam--
you can form that by drawing
the perpendicular bisectors
between the random points.
So each cell contains
the points that
are closer to the nucleation
point than any other point--
or any other nucleation point.
And if we just do this process
as I've described here,
you end up with a
Voronoi structure,
where the cells appear
kind of angular.
And if you specify an
exclusion distance,
where you say the nucleation
points can't be closer
than a certain
distance, then the cells
become less angular, and
of more similar size.
OK.
So are we good with the Voronoi
honeycomb nucleation and growth
idea?
Alrighty.
All right.
If we think about cell shape--
if we start with honeycombs
and we just think about it
hexagonal honeycombs, if I have
a regular hexagonal honeycomb
so that all the edges are
the same length and this
angle here is 30 degrees,
then that is an
isotropic material
in the plane in the
linear elastic regime.
One of the things
we're going to do
is calculate-- if I
loan it this way on,
what's the Young's modulus?
If I load it that way on,
And we're going to find they're
the same, in fact, no matter
which way on I loaded it.
It would be the same.
But if I now have my honeycomb,
and imagine that I stretched it
out-- and I'm kind of
exaggerating how much we
might stretch it out.
But if we did
something like that,
it wouldn't be too surprising
to think that the properties are
going to be different if
I loaded it this way on
and that way on.
And in terms of
the cell geometry,
I'm going to call that
vertical cell edge length h.
And I'm going to call this one--
the inclined one-- of length l.
I'm going to say that
angle is the angle theta.
And the cell shape can be
defined by the ratio of h
over l and that angle theta.
OK.
When we derive equations for
the mechanical properties
of the honeycombs, we're
going to find that they depend
on some solid properties.
Say, the modulus
of the honeycombs
can depend on the
modulus of the solid.
It's going to depend on
the relative density raised
to some power.
And we're going to
figure out what that is.
And then it's going
to depend, also,
on some function of
h over l and theta.
And that function really
represents the contribution
of the cell geometry to
the mechanical properties.
OK.
That's the honeycombs.
It's fairly straightforward to
characterize the shell shape
for the honeycombs.
It's a little more involved
to do it for the foams.
And the technique that's used
is called the mean intercept
length.
At least, that's one
technique that's used.
Let me wait until
you've finished
writing because
I want you to see
the picture as I talk about it.
OK?
OK.
Here's-- whoops.
My pointer keeps disappearing.
This top left picture here
shows an SEM image of a foam.
And you can see, you've got
some big cells and little cells
and there's no obvious way to
characterize the cell shape.
And what people do to calculate
this mean intercept length
is they would take an image.
They would then sketch
out just the cell edges
that touch a plane's surface.
So all these black
lines are just the--
if you took your-- if
you put ink on your foam
and you just put it on a pad
and put it on a piece of paper,
you would get this outline of
the edges of the cells, where
they intersect that plane.
And then what people do
is they draw test circles.
Here's the test circle here.
And they draw parallel
equiaxed, or equidistant lines.
So the lines here are parallel.
They're all at,
say, zero degrees.
And they're all the
same distance apart.
And then they count the
number of intercepts.
They count-- say
we went out here.
The cell wall intercepts here.
There's one that
intercepts here.
And then, it'd go up here.
Here's another intercept.
So they count the number of
intercepts of the cell wall
with the lines.
And then they get a
mean intercept length,
which is characteristic
of the cell dimension.
And then what they do--
because this is just
in one orientation--
you would then
rotate those parallel
lines by, say, 5 degrees
and do it all over again.
And get another length
at 5 degrees and one
at 10 degrees one at 15.
And so you get different
lengths for the intercepts
as you rotate your
parallel lines around.
And then you make a
polar plot, and that's
what the thing is down
at the bottom here.
And so you plot your
mean intercept length
as a function of the angle
that you measured it at.
And you can fit
it to an ellipse.
And if you do it in
three dimensions,
you fit it to an ellipsoid.
And the major and minor axes
of that ellipse, or ellipsoid,
are characteristic of
how elongated the cell is
in the different directions.
And the orientation
of that ellipsoid
is characteristic of the
orientation of the cells.
Those of you who took 303, too,
you remember Mohr's circles?
Is this beginning
to look familiar?
It's the same kind of
idea as Mohr's circles.
Same way we have principal
stresses and orientation
of principal stresses, now
we have principal dimensions
and the orientation of
the principal dimensions.
So it's the same kind of idea.
OK?
Let's see.
I feel like I'm getting
to the end here.
Maybe I'll stop there for today.
But next time, I'll write
down the whole technique
about how we get
these mean intercepts
and get this ellipsoid.
And I'm going to write the mean
intercepts down as a matrix.
But you could also
write it as a tensor.
And there's something
called the fabric
tensor, which characterizes
the shape of the cells.
And as you might imagine, the
same is with the honeycomb.
If you have equiaxed
cells in the foams,
you might expect you would
get isotropic properties.
If you have cells that are
stretched out in some way--
so you've got different
principal dimensions for them--
then you've got
anisotropic material.
And you can relate how much
anisotropy to the shape
of the cells.
OK.
I'm going to stop
there for today.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Seems very sudden.
I'll pick up and I'll finish
this section on the structure.
We've got a bit more to do.
And then we'll start looking
at honeycombs and modeling
honeycombs.
The honeycombs are
simpler to model
just because they have
this nice simple unit cell.
So we'll start with
that, and then we'll
move from there to the foams.
OK?